bonsoir à tous commençons par une
devinette
à votre avis quel est le point commun
entre ces organismes vivants un
champignon
si si je vous l'affirmé c'est un
champignon du mimosa une mouche un
hamster est un être humain
vous allez me répondre a priori aucun et
bien si tous ces organismes vivent selon
des rythmes biologiques et
comportementaux et c'est une question de
survie
à l'échelle de l'espèce mais aussi à
l'échelle de l'individu
tous les êtres vivants sont soumis à des
variations de l'environnement des
variations cycliques de leur
environnement est la solution pour faire
face à ce problème
eh bien c'est la rythmicité les rythmes
sont universels on les retrouve dans le
règne végétal aussi bien que dans le
règne animal
ils permettent aux organismes
d'anticiper ces variations périodiques
de l'environnement et s'y adapter en
ajustant leurs réponses physiologiques
alors ce soit je veux vous parler de
deux types de rythme en particulier qui
sont liées à des phénomènes géophysique
immuable
le premier de ces rythmes apr origine la
rotation de la terre sur son axe et ce
mouvement conduit à l'alternance des
jours et des nuits
cette alternance de jour et nuit est
appelée rythme nict énéral harnik
t'aimer râle ça vient du grec nuque
tenero qui comprend deux mots nuxe nuque
tos pour nuit et hemera pour jour alors
mon cours d'un dîner
si vous voulez en acheter un peu
n'hésitez pas allez paris d'une journée
parler d'un nycthémère à articuler parce
que ça pourrait prêter à confusion
donc tous ces êtres vivants sont soumis
à ces rythmes géophysique
nick tenero et ce qui compte ce a
conduit en fait à l'émergence chez ces
êtres vivants de rythme journalier ou
circadien alors circadien là cette fois
ça vient du latin circadienne qu'ici
hi fi environ 1 jour en effet ces
rythmes ont une période de 24 heures et
peu de rythme sont aussi répandus dans
dans le monde vivent alors je peux vous
vous citez évidemment en premier lieu
que ce que vous connaissez bien les
cycle veille sommeil mais notre activité
physique et notre activité
intellectuelle aussi sont soumis à des
rythmes
il ya des moments de la journée on est
très actif très concentré on est très
vigilant et d'autres moments on a qu'une
envie c'est d'aller faire la sieste et
j'en parlerai tout à l'heure également
des rythmes le rythme de température
aussi notre température corporelle varie
au cours d'une journée elle n'augmente
pendant le jour et puis elle diminue
pendant la nuit
toutes ces fonctions biologiques toutes
ses fonctions physiologiques sont
circadienne alors les rythmes sont
connues depuis l'antiquité ils ont été
décrits par de nombreux naturaliste
pline l'ancien aristote théophraste et
pour eux il traduisait la symbiose des
êtres vivants autant cosmique
les premières observations sur les
rythmes en fait ont été obtenues par
l'étude du règne végétal par par des
botanistes et l'un d'entre eux carl von
linné avait proposé une horloge floral
avait proposé dans l'eau florale
parce que il avait remarqué que
certaines fleurs s'ouvrent
s'épanouissent et se referment à des
heures précises de la journée et ce quel
que soit le temps donc
en inspectant son jardin carl von linné
pouvait connaître leur plus besoin de
montres très poétique mais pas pratique
donc plus tard les chronobiologistes les
scientifiques qui étudient les rythmes
communauté scientifique à laquelle
j'appartiens se sont interrogés sur la
net sur l'origine avant sur l'origine de
ces rythmes à savoir est ce que ces
rythmes sont d'origine endogène est ce
qu'ils sont produits par l'organisme par
les organismes même ou alors ces rites
sont ils le résultat l'impact direct de
l'environnement sur les organismes
vivants et bien la première réponse à
cette question a été apportée par
un scientifique français un astronome
jean jacques dor tous de mayran cet
astronome avait remarqué que le mimosa
connu pour sa capacité à ouvrir ses
feuilles au lever du jour et les
refermer à la tombée de la nuit
conservez cette propriété même s'il
était maintenu à l'obscurité constante
il s'agissait donc là de la première
preuve expérimentale de l'existence d'un
rite intrinsèque à cette langue dari
endogène plus tard bien plus tard les
scientifiques dont sa date du siècle
dernier quand même un dans les années 70
les chronobiologistes se sont interrogés
cette fois sur la nature des rythmes et
en fait les curieusement les les
informations les plus pertinentes pour
répondre à cette question ont été
obtenus en utilisant un modèle assez
surprenant en utilisant un modèle qui
est une espèce de mouche la mouche du
vinaigre ou drosophiles que vous avez vu
au début et grâce à cette mouche on sait
maintenant que les rythmes sont
gouvernés par des gènes qu'on appelle
des gènes horloge parce qu'on
interagissons entre eux il compose des
petites horloges moléculaires qui sont
présents dans chacune de nos cellules
j'étais trop vite dans chacune de nos
cellules
chez les mammifères on sait que tous ces
petites horloges dans l'ensemble de nos
cellules sont gouvernés par une horloge
maîtresse qui est localisée à la base de
notre cerveau dans une zone qui bat
comme un métronome et donne la mesure du
temps à notre organisme
on l'appelle cette zone les noyaux supra
climatique ils sont composés de vingt
mille cellules nerveuses 20000 neurones
et ils sont localisés au dessus du
classement optique c'est la raison pour
laquelle il on les appelle les noyaux
supra 4matic stratégiquement positionné
au croisement des nerfs optiques
alors lorsque ces noyaux supra
qu'asiatique sont endommagés inutile de
vous dire que les rythme disparaissent
complètement c'est très chaotique le
cycle veille sommeil sont complètement
aberrant bref on perd la boussole un jeu
comme je voulais dit plus tôt le les
rythmes
circadien ont une période d'environ 24
heures mais c'est pas très précis quand
même hein et ça a été vérifié par des
expériences très célèbre qui ont été
menées par un géologue français très
connu qui s'appelle michel siffre et qui
a accepté l'idée d'aller dans une grotte
complètement isolée de toutes les
informations provenant de l'extérieur et
il est il à répéter cette expérience à
plusieurs reprises et il était observé
par des scientifiques
bilan de ces observations l'horloge
biologique de michel siffre comme celle
de nous tous bah en 25 heures environ
alors évidemment en 25 heures
c'est plus long c'est plus long que le
rythme de rotation de la terre sur sur
son axe donc il faut en permanence
recalée cette horloge biologique c'est
nécessaire et le moyen que la plupart
des êtres vivants utilisent pour recaler
cette horloge biologique et bien c'est
d'utiliser des repères temporels qu'on
appelle aussi d'honneur de temps et le
principal donneur de temps c'est la
lumière et en particulier la lumière
bleue le spectre bleutée de la lumière
voilà qui apparaît là maintenant devant
vous alors là là avec cette lumière
bleue devant vos yeux elle vient là là
les photons lumineux vaut en sont en
train en ce moment de cibler certaines
cellules de votre rétine qui sont
directement connectés à vos noix you
supra casse matic et qui sont en train
de les stimuler
voilà donc vous êtes un petit peu plus
réveillez vous allez pouvoir et écouter
la suite de ce dont je veux vous parler
et plus précisément du second type de
rythme je vais vous parler maintenant
d'un rythme un autre rythme 10 et celui
ci aussi un phénomène géophysiques
il s'agit de du mouvement de rotation de
la terre autour du soleil et ce
mouvement entraîne l'alternance des
saisons dans les zones tempérées
alors mais évidemment tout le monde sait
que
les saisons et bien c'est une période
très agréable où les températures sont
clémentes la nourriture est abondante
pour tous les tous les animaux qui sont
ce qu'ils sont sous ces latitudes suivie
d'une période où au contraire les
températures sont très rudes
la nourriture est rare et bien cette
alternance a permis l'instauration de
rythme annuel chez certaines espèces et
vous les connaissez bien c'est rythme
annuel ils nous entourent tous alors il
s'agit de la migration pour les oiseaux
par exemple il s'agit également du
changement de plage pour certains
animaux changement de couleur changement
d'épaisseur et puis certains animaux
préfèrent carrément hiberner dans une
dans un petit terrier c'est le cas de
notre hamster du début et il existe
aussi une autre fonction qui est annuel
c'est la fonction de reproduction et
celle ci est particulièrement étudiée
par les scientifiques parce que de cette
programmation annuelle de la fonction de
répondu de reproduction des pans rien de
moins que la survie des espèces et leur
pérennité
donc elle est très étudié évidemment
parce que vous n'avez jamais vu
d'oisillons naître en plein mois de
décembre
donc vous n'avez pas non plus vu
d'agneau gambader dans la neige et non
en effet chez c'est chez tous ces
animaux les la programmation des
naissances est très précisément arrive
très précisément au moment où leurs
chances de survie sont maximale
c'est-à-dire au moment au mont printemps
ou au début de l'été et tout ça grâce à
une programmation antérieures de la
fonction de reproduction qui elle aura
eu lieu quelques semaines voire quelques
mois auparavant
c'est bien fait quand même non voilà
donc là je viens de vous parler du monde
animal mais nous aussi humain nous
sommes aussi soumis à l'alternance des
saisons et d'ailleurs au début du 19e
siècle dans certains villages de france
les registres des naissances indiqué que
plus de bébés naissaient en juillet
en août et cela en relation avec le fait
que neuf mois plus tôt en octobre et
novembre les hommes produisent plus de
testostérone l'hormone qui est impliqué
dans le comportement sexuel ça vous
parle messieurs
bon inutile de vous dire que aujourd'hui
de nos jours on ne constate plus cette
saisonnalité delà de la reproduction
cette saisonnalité des naissances et les
chez les humains évidemment puisque on
est sous la lumière artificielle quand
on veut on est et puis les pratiques
culturelles moderne si la prise de la
pilule contraceptive ont complètement
effacé cette saisonnalité mais en
revanche on est quand même sensible à
certains facteurs et hong kong on
constate quand même une certaine analyse
annualisation des rythmes annuels existe
perdure encore
et par exemple je vais vous citer le
fait que nous sommes plus sensibles aux
maladies infectieuses pendant l'hiver là
où au moment où nos défenses
immunitaires sont au plus bas
et puis on observe aussi un pic de
pathologies cardiovasculaires à la fin
de l'hiver au moment où la pression
artérielle atteint son maximum annuel
alors inutile de vous dire que avec tout
ce que je viens de vous raconter ça ne
vous surprendra pas d'apprendre que les
perturbations de ses proches de cette
horloge les l'altération de ses rythmes
peut avoir des conséquences importantes
sur notre physiologie et on voit
d'ailleurs à l'occasion d'un décalage
horaire quand on change de fuseaux
horaires il faut plusieurs jours à notre
organisme pour se recaler c'est qui
correspond à la période nécessaire à
notre horloge biologique pour se mettre
en phase avec l'alternance des jours et
des nuits qui correspond à l'endroit où
nous arrivons dans le cas de
perturbations
chronique et répété là on commence à
comprendre que des perturbations dans
chroniques et répétées peuvent avoir des
conséquences un petit peu plus lourds
peuvent participer à des pathologies
comme l'obésité le diabète
bon al'inverse on a vraiment beaucoup à
gagner
on a vraiment beaucoup de profit à tirer
de l'étude du fonctionnement de nos
rythmes et de notre horloge biologique
et c'est particulièrement vrai quand on
pense à la chronothérapie ya un principe
qui est appliquée de plus en plus et
avec succès en milieu hospitalier
maintenant je vous parle et non d'une
observation assez récente qui a été fait
par les chronobiologistes qui date de
quelques dizaines d'années et ils ont
constaté une dérive de nos rythmes
biologiques en effet notre phase de
repos diminue au profit de notre phase
d'activité ce qui conduit à la perte
d'environ une à deux heures de sommeil
en moyenne par nuit c'est énorme et ça a
évidemment en lien aussi avec la lumière
artificielle avec nos pratiques
culturelles moderne qui nous permet de
nous connecter à tout moment de la
journée et de la nuit avec n'importe qui
sur la planète
donc nous grignotons notre phase de
repos pour être pour rester actifs plus
longtemps et c'est vraiment quelque
chose auquel on doit penser et qu'on
doit peut-être arrivé à corriger aussi
donc voilà je voulais terminer en vous
disant combien pour moi scientifique
c'est impressionnant de voir à quel
point tous les êtres vivants sont
intimement liés à ces rythmes naturels
et j'espère vous avoir fait un petit peu
partagé ce sentiment
ce soir notre horloge biologique est un
mécanisme constitutifs de la nature même
des êtres vivants elle nous a aidé à
survivre nous a aidés à nous adapter à
ce milieu toujours changeants alors
sachons l'écouté
sachons la respecter par exemple
éteignons nos portables smartphones
ordinateurs qui entre parenthèses
émettent une lumière bleue
insidieusement et 2 et ennio les deux
heures avant le coucher et puis besson
progressivement les lumières au cours de
la soirée
et puis pourquoi ne pas tenir compte de
nos rythmes biologiques dans notre
organisation sociale
c'est vrai ce qu'il ya des entrepreneurs
dans la salle oui bon eh bien pourquoi
ne pas permettre à vos employés de faire
une sieste au moment où leur vigilance
est au minimum leur capacité de
concentration également et pourquoi ne
pas tenir compte de ces critères pour
organiser les équipes
les horaires des équipes de travail bon
je sais que certains ont déjà franchi le
pas petit à petit les idées font leur
chemin
à chacun son rythme merci